he is one of the most exciting fighters
on the ufc roster he's coming off the
fight of the year against justin gaichy
we flew him all the way from nashville
tennessee it's michael chandler on
today's food truck diaries and i'm
feeding them
breakfast burritos
super thick from my wallet to my check i
don't want it if it's skinny but i need
it if it's thick
need a thick girl
put it big boy
[Music]
options
it's beautiful just drove through the
canyon
nice right santa monica came from santa
monica via nashville dude i mean are we
fighting next week that's what we're
trying to do
insanely in shape i'm trying to be in
shape i mean i i try not to get out of
shape as you know everybody knows yeah
the further you get out of shape the
harder it is to get back into shape so i
try to stay in i mean obviously last
fight was a banger so i
mean there's around i mean i got a
little up there yeah i got i had a
couple a couple sets of stitches with
your stitches in my mouth oh really yeah
and obviously took a bunch of leg kicks
landed a bunch of leg kicks so like
legs were a little beat up yeah we'll
get into the game plan
but uh i'm not sure there was one yeah
the game plan was entertaining it was
entertaining yeah which i think
won you more fans than
anything yeah but you're you're fully
healed everything's all good fully
healed man i feel great it's it's uh it
really is a blessing man i've been doing
it this long and not having a lot of a
lot of injuries after some of the wars
i've been in has been been pretty good
it's a testament to recovery and treat
my body right obviously but it's agree
being a professional making sure you do
the proper things that we're trying to
so as far as timeline next fight what do
we think sometime this summer i always i
always said obviously when i was limping
around after the last one i wanted to
wait till this summer um so we'll see i
mean they're talking may possibly no no
uh
no contracts yet no about agreements no
contract no bad agreements but you know
rumor
tony ferguson rumor is tony ferguson
which is an electrifying fight
electrifying fight i think it's a i mean
and we kind of have some history too
because we shared a card uh back in may
sure you know that was when the dana
white privilege was was born
right so
you know and tony's tony's just tony's
the guy man he's you know he's one of
the most decorated guys in the you've
got to respect it perspective
yeah and and if you look at his body of
work the guys he's beat in the way that
he's beat guys and then he's still you
know he's still a very dangerous guy
scary guy a little crazy got a screw
loose which makes for a fun fight i
agree and i would i hope that fight
happens i hope he gets announced soon
and i do think with tony too like when
he was in his prime when you're talking
prime tony when he's like nine in a row
to me
him or khabib his argument as far as
best 155 is walking the freaking planet
100 and it's and it's crazy and
unfortunate that that fight never
materialized it was booked like four or
five times
but i think what tony brings to the
table back then during that 12 fight win
streak and also even now he's just he's
unorthodox you can't you can't put him
out unless you absolutely put him out
you need to separate him from
consciousness as we as we've seen um and
he's just
to me as when i look at it as an athlete
it's a little bit of a it's a hard it's
a hard guy to prepare for because there
is no other style like tony ferguson
yeah it's almost like a wonder boy or
something where you know they have that
weird style we can try to bring guys in
to mimic
that style but you're not gonna find you
really you don't get a get a vibe of
tony to inside the octagon 100 it's
tough to figure it out for sure and even
when you're watching it as a fan or me
as a as a fellow competitor in the same
weight class you're just like
because it's awkward and so much of this
sport too isn't just the physicality of
it it's it's the mental aspect and so
whenever he's reaching down and throwing
up sanders
yeah and that was part of the same thing
with the gaichi fight there was a little
bit of gamesmanship slash
the mental side of things
going on inside of there then there was
just the physicality punches
in that fight so we're gonna get to that
but you probably don't fight to mace
like you do you eat breakfast or you
want those guys okay well i mean i eat
breakfast here at the thanks man i'm on
a diet too so it might be weird but let
me feed you
continue this
[Music]
do you know what you want yeah i'll hold
her first if you want steak and eggs how
are you doing boss
i'm great man yeah thanks for doing this
man i'm excited this looks like a legit
truck you're way upstairs
my son's a
marine right now and he literally went
into the marine corps
to uh work on his mma skills oh damn
that's kind of what
like the mcmap yeah right yeah because
they have the training program oh they
do they have mma training programs yeah
i think it's called mcmap right right
marine office or what's up okay yeah
yeah they have the training here right
now he's got 29 pounds right now oh damn
tell me he said what's up man yeah we'll
send them a video or something
yeah no
guys having us problem of course doing
this uh can i can i do the steak and
eggs but uh no french fries or cheese
dang dude
yep no fries no cheese so i should have
went first no fries no cheese i think
that's what i'm gonna do do it dude i
just look like a follower yeah because
you gotta have steak carnivore [ __ ] i
know
i eat like a big cat at the zoo son
i'll do uh i'll do the steak and eggs as
well no
no french fries no cheese and i'll do
scrambled eggs okay do you guys want to
use water coffee a little water
i'll do a coffee you have diet coke too
no diet coke yeah it's great uh just a
coffee calories here yeah i know yeah
i'll just copy them for me two coffees
actually i'll do a coffee as well okay
and then uh
yes uh some salsa on the side or
something yeah sure hot sauce on the
side yeah it's on the side we'll put it
on the bottom
oh yeah perfect yeah we'll do that and
we've got many donuts too we'll send
some over all right yeah might as well
put them out there
put them out there
thank you sir yeah got it thank you
little mini donuts coming out of the
truck man no dude
[Applause]
[Music]
chicken
let's take a little break from stuffing
our faces with the great michael
chandler because listen i got something
to tell you man
a lot of y'all don't want to go to the
gym right now you're looking for a new
fresh workout i gotcha i've been a
member for
five years now we're talking about
peloton peloton is pushing you further
with so much they even got new stuff
with their pelton bikes bikes plus new
classes new music new ways to keep your
workouts fun motivating all right and
now the new stuff is what i'm excited to
tell you about they got boxing that's
right peloton boxing pelting is stepping
into the ring with its newest discipline
no gloves needed it's fast it's fierce
it's fun pelton instructors are in your
corner to get you a workout that you're
going to love they have new artists
music selections pelton's adding fun new
artist series classes work out the music
of a single artist for an entire class
from your favorite hits to the deep cuts
we're talking pop rock hip hop edm they
have over 100 artist series to choose
from so you never get bored with your
workout man you get a great workout in
all right they got daily workout
varieties it's easier to stick to your
workout when you mix it up you don't get
bored of the same stuff every time man
all right they got 20 minutes of cardio
how about a quick 15 minute total body
class before you head to work why not
get your thick body in shape man stay
motivated motivated while having fun
with a bike that works out you can do
yoga meditation dance cardio boxing what
are you waiting for man let's get in
shape it's 20 22 visit onepeloton.com to
learn more that's one peloton.com o n e
p e l o t o n dot com one peloton all
right my man let's dig on in i uh
i didn't read the fine print i didn't
know it was a burrito oh i know we're a
truck
dude you're right when you're right
you're right
so i can't have that tortilla
so you unwrap that um
yeah man you know i
for you like
i think what's interesting about you is
you know finally you're in the ufc i
feel like you you're more famous than
ever
you know your your losses you've gained
more notoriety more fans i don't you
haven't it didn't hurt you does that
make sense like you're in a weird
situation where
yeah you have lost your last two
but you've won so many people over and i
think now you've won the trust of the
ufc which is huge yeah and then also you
got thrown to the you got thrown to the
wolves man you know you got you got dan
hooker which
a ridiculous fight one you know great
knockout one of the best knockouts of
the year and then you know
you get charles oliveira where you got
first round ten eight to main ten eight
rounds so clearly you know you're at
that level then you get the justin
gaichi fight which is you know fight of
the year so
you know it's tough to look at and go ah
man he made the wrong choice going to
the ufc it's like no no no no don't let
the record fool you man this guy's
crushing it yeah one and that's that's
truthfully what i asked for i mean i sat
there
in hunter campbell's office and we and i
just i told him i said hey man i'm you
know
at that point i was 34
years old still very young in the sport
for being 34 and i said hey i just want
to i want to come in and either prove i
i am who i say i am or i'm not you know
like i want to be i want a top five guy
right away
and it wasn't because i thought i
deserved because i think that was what a
lot of people thought too well hey who's
this guy think he is coming in and
calling shots i wasn't calling shots let
me go in there and let me go in there
and fall flat on my face go 0-2 and you
guys cut me correct i'll be able to live
with that yeah because that means i
wasn't good enough
um
so obviously came in tony ferguson was
the first name on on the list poirier
was the second name they both said no
for for legitimate reasons i would never
hold that against them these guys have
cut their teeth in the ufc for a decade
i'm a new guy coming in everybody had a
lot to lose not a lot stack division two
stack division exactly so dan hooker
said yes and then you know we went to
abu dhabi and did that i was before that
i was the backup and i think that's what
what an intro to the ufc knockout was
insane i mean it was it was good and it
worked out i mean obviously it worked
out really well um
and then and then it was just if you
just look at the whole thing too there
was just some interesting circumstances
because
did i deserve the title shot after that
win no but yeah yeah
necessarily but you have poirier and i
agree with that because i think
you know
we live in a time right now where it's
like we're not in normal times
and
you look at your body of work outside of
the ufc in bellator you talk about face
of bellator you know world champion and
so it's like
you're doing work just in a different
way so
you know i saw guys complaining
especially
you know i love justin gates he was a
training partner for many years and we
have the same coach i absolutely love
justin he's gates phenomenal fighter
bonnie is like this guy needs to earn it
i'm like bro you came from world series
of five like it's the same [ __ ] and now
you're gonna well and it was actually
and i don't think i've ever brought this
up on on camera or an interview but it
was the exact same path he came in and
fought michael johnson yeah man who was
number five in the world right away i
fought dan hooker who was number five in
the world right away we both win
then
he fights eddie alvarez which would have
given him a title shot because eddie had
just come off of the loss of of winning
the world title is number two in the
world at that point so if he beats he
would
it will yeah he lost to connor eddie did
but if gaichi would have beat alvarez he
would have had the next title shot so
maybe i got a title shot one fight
before gateshead but it was also a
different division the division is
always always moving and it's the
fastest moving sport in the entire world
things change at the drop of a hat so
you know and it also just is a testament
to and i sat there and i looked across
the table at hunter campbell i said i i
want to be the guy who comes in and does
and says yes to every opportunity and
that's exactly what i did i said i
nobody else would have been the backup
and made weight and went to
although you know and then i said yes to
dan hooker and i said yes i've said i've
said yes since the very beginning and
as an employee as a as someone on a
roster under a contract in any any walk
of life any industry the person who
works the hardest and says yes and puts
the best foot forward should be rewarded
and that's the way i see it i agree um
so just part of it and i i think too you
know
would you have changed anything when
you're looking back at it again you're
one and two but
you know you've won the fans over and
then also you've won the trust of the
ufc so for the ufc to know
if they put you on a card it's you're
looking at a performance bonus you know
the guy's not gonna just hold a guy down
and you know wrestle him to get the win
like he's there to win the fans over so
that's huge would you have changed
anything because i'll be dead honest
with you
with the adjusting gauchee fight i was
like you know gentlemen can [ __ ]
wrestle man let's get after let's do
this let's shoot that blast double your
signature blast double let's get this
dude down and you're like nah i'm good
would i have changed anything about my
about my game playing for in the gate
chief what you're saying or fight
i would say in general because
you know you came out like a freaking
banshee man you know you starch hooker
you you know you go out there and you
really 10-8 rounding at charles oliveira
if that fight goes that first round
there's another 30 seconds price stop
you're the world champ we're talking
about a different conversation right now
so
would you i guess
because i would say you you've kind of
come to your own and you're this
electrifying like
exciting fighter now i don't know if i
would say don't get me wrong you were
exciting bellator but you're a different
animal now
but you are one and two would you would
you change anything i think you know
you're a fan favorite you know it's like
a double-edged it's a it's a
double-edged sword and it's hard to i
mean you you are who you are to a
certain extent you know i
when i look back and i look back and i
look at the fight
numerous fights i mean there's been
numerous times in the past where it's
bit me and i you know
if i was a little bit more methodical a
little bit more um patient a little bit
more of a veteran maybe i would have won
a couple of the fights that i've lost
but
at some point too you just are who you
are you know when that cage door closes
i want to get in your face right away
because once again we go back to the the
mental aspect of the sport you can only
pour it on a guy for so long where he
either breaks or he stands up to the
challenge and then you got to fight on
your hands that's what happened with
justin gaichi that's what happened with
charles oliveira um which i was
surprised you know he has that you know
history of it and i know people like i
can't believe you bring that up it's
like we bring it up for a reason we've
seen him quit in fights before and a
person can't adapt and change but to me
if that gene that quit gene's in there
it's going to come out it might not come
out in the first round like you're used
to or the second round but in
championship fights they come out in the
fourth to fit like that gene's in there
if you're fighting a guy like you who
has no quit in your mentalities to break
this dude you know i'll take those odds
man yeah i know and that's and that's
where i that's where i've said
i think charles oliveira has has
surprised a lot of people with the way
that he's he's now come on as the
champion
and then finishing dustin poirier and
then i mean with each one of those wins
whether it's for the title you're the
champion or not each one of those wins
inside the ufc you gain more and more
confidence or at least you should as
long as you have the right people around
you the right training scenario and
you're taking care of your body but um
yeah the way he has continued to gain
steam is is uh it's something to behold
and it's really it's really cool and the
the great thing too now is we got gaichi
and oliveira fighting each other um
i think a lot of people would want to
see a rematch of myself versus either
those guys so i've kind of put myself in
a position where
who knows what happens with the win over
tony ferguson i don't know if i got to
fight
two more fights three more fights to get
back in the title or if i get a title
shot after that i don't i don't know all
i can do is train show up do my job say
yes to every opportunity and and see
where the call the cards fall do you
feel any pressure now to to be that guy
you know to get the performance of the
night you know the fight another fight
of the year type of vibe like with tony
if that fight does come with fruition
like with tony like that has
fight of the year written all over it no
i don't actually well i don't feel that
pressure because i know i know who i am
and i know that i'm capable of that
without even trying to without even
putting any pressure on myself i think
i think in this in this sport
the mental side of things people people
try to put that pressure on themselves
to
to change who they are to get themselves
up to be that that guy
unfortunately at some time i mean
fortunately but unfortunately too i am
that guy i love to go in there and brawl
i love i i see i have no fears
whatsoever when i'm inside of there
i want to get in the fire i want to get
into the into the fight a legitimate
fight and i think
and i do and i think and i think that's
that's what i said too and i gave props
to justin gaichi we we are
who we are who we said we were yep and
we did what we said we were going to do
i mean how many times in this sport have
you seen guys talk and talk and talk
just to go out there and play it safe
take backwards steps agree not
not go out there and really try to get
into and i'm not saying you have to go
out there and brawl but go out there
with the indomitable spirit that you're
you're not going to take a step
backwards and and in the face of
adversity you're not going to quit when
you go back to your stool you're going
to regain your faculties go back out
there and try to finish the fight
i know that about myself i can trust
myself when i'm in there and i think
that's one of the most beautiful things
whenever you know you can trust yourself
in any scenario if you can't trust
yourself how are you how are you ever
going to truly believe that you're going
to be successful so
i don't feel any kind of extra pressure
it's just ingrained in me which is not
always not always a great thing yeah um
but it's uh it's fun it's been fun to
watch man it's been fun to watch i think
you know the tony ferguson fight for me
makes so much sense i think the fans
will be pretty excited about it it seems
like tony's up for the challenge yeah
we've talked a little bit there's been a
lot of guys who you know
yeah you've been in the news with conor
mcgregor right like connor seems to be
he'll be your huckleberry i think
especially if you put on a big
performance against tony ferguson you
know
fighting for the title fighting justin
gaychu who's fighting for the title a
big win over tony ferguson is a huge
name in the division
you know
i know they say oh you know conor might
get a title shot right away i don't
think so i don't think that's the way
they're going to work so i could
definitely see them giving you a conor
mcgregor which you're talking
life-changing money yeah you know like
i to me you know and dustin poirey said
it best he's like man i fight for money
so when they offered me the title or
conor mcgregor i said conor mcgregor and
obviously paid off for him i think same
thing with you man
yeah i think um
you know me and connor have
talked on twitter or whatever and
there's been a mutual respect i mean for
me
i don't need to hate a guy to go out
there and try to kill him you know and i
do love that about my mentality it works
well for me
but i think a win over tony ferguson
does put me in that talk and i'll be
ready if connor wants to come back in
july august i'll i'll turn around right
away that's what he said fight him late
late this summer i think uh
you know i think
diaz really is the is the wild card did
he resign a new deal yet i i don't know
i i have a news on it right i don't i
haven't heard any news yet either so i
think he's kind of the wild card
obviously you have poirier and diaz
talking to each other um which makes
sense to me which yeah that fight does
make sense but obviously
the i think the biggest fight that the
ufc can make is conor versus diaz right
yeah you know those two aren't like nate
diaz is never gonna be able to leave the
ufc without doing the trilogy and that's
but to me like i think ufc knows that
fight's always there so they're trying
to drain as much
out of the irishman as they can and
finally go all right here's here's the
trilogy fight we all want to see it yeah
and and
if anybody could come right back and
skip the line and fight for the title it
would be conor obviously
um but
like you said i don't see that happening
um so am i on that short list of guys
that he would come back and fight
maybe and for me obviously yeah you talk
about life-changing money
you talk about it's a great business
decision but for me
i think i spent so many years outside of
the ufc feeling like i was under
i was just undervalued or i was under
i don't want to say appreciated because
i felt appreciated
yeah well yeah by the fans just because
there wasn't as much of an
as much of a
a multitude of eyeballs on me you know i
was putting on these performances and i
was training i mean the hardest part too
was
training around all these guys who were
getting all this credit and getting all
these in the ufc yeah because they were
in the ufc and i and i saw the way that
they lived their lives i saw the way
that they trained i saw the way that
they they conducted themselves as a as
an athlete and i was just
i saw the way that i did it and i
thought it was i'm by no means perfect
but i was as professional as you could
differently yeah
and and i just and i just felt and i
felt like now coming into the ufc i want
the biggest fights and that doesn't come
without saying yes i said yes to every
opportunity obviously so the connor
fight intrigues me because it's it's a
big big big fight you know there's
there's nothing bigger than that so of
course the money is great and the you
know the paycheck and the business side
of things but
for me
getting to share the octagon with him as
part of my you know latter part of my
career that's dude that's what is that's
what excites me you know having these
big stages big moments big opportunities
that's what you wanted what you've
gotten i mean think about it hooker yeah
freaking you know fighting for the title
against charles oliveira the justin
gaichy if the ferguson fight does happen
connor it's like yeah this guy made the
right choice coming over to ufc yeah
you're talking about literally the
biggest names division yeah that's why
you came over for it yeah and 100 too i
mean i i just i do remember when i was
thinking about making the decision do i
resign with military do i go to the ufc
obviously the intrigue of the ufc was it
was it was where i knew i i needed to go
if i wanted to check that box too of
the 40 year old me
was i gonna be able to sleep at night
knowing that in my career i never went
to the ufc to go test myself some people
say i went too late some people will say
i never should have went most people
would say it's worked it's worked out
ever since
yeah it's worked out it's like being the
best quarterback in cfl i'm like i'm
good yeah and it's like well the nfl you
know i'll give you a shot man you know
and they don't go but
i'm not
degrading bellator you know but you know
the elephants in the room you know the
ufc is the nfl of mixed martial arts
i'll end on this
looking at the matchups tony first and
conor mcgregor is there
which one do you think is uh easier path
to victory free tony because they you're
talking about two completely different
animals right like connor you know i
have to worry about grappling anything
like that obviously stand-up's
ridiculous but he is you know we don't
know where he's at mentally yeah he
looks great on
social media he's jacked super jacked he
has a dick all in my face he was like
doing a pull-up all right dude
which i'm a huge i'm a connor dick
writer so i want to see him come back
and do well but then with tony it's like
you have this guy you know he's coming
off a few losses but he's still a fan
favorite and there's something that's
intriguing about him and you know you
you can't really train for him or plan
for him so you're talking about two
different
flavors here yeah is there one where if
you obviously let's take money out of it
notoriety is there one that would be the
easier path to get a title shot you
think um i
to get to actually to get to the title
shot i don't know i think they're both
kind of similar obviously you got connor
coming back and you got tony who's got a
couple losses but i have a couple losses
everybody has losses in eoc you're not
fighting tough enough guys if you're
undefeated exactly right um
i think i think tony might be a tougher
puzzle to solve just because inside he's
less predictable not that conor is
predictable he's a phenomenal athlete um
but
what you see with conor is a lot of
times what you get and it's it's a hard
it's a it's a it's a hard puzzle to
solve but once it's it's much less
predictable um or it's much more
predictable and i think tony just brings
that
he brings that little bit of uh
uncertainty at all times
he's unorthodox you know his darsh
chokes his anacondas he's him from all
these angles plus his cardio he never
slows down he gets better as the fight
goes on his cardio doesn't slow down
he's an absolute freaking warrior you
know his face he you know you take him
down you have issues with his elbows and
[ __ ] it's like tony's a tough he is
which you know it excites me too because
those are the kind of fights and and i
hate i hate to sit here and act like
fighting conor wouldn't make me wake up
earlier or make you know keep me up at
night obviously that would but there's
something about the craziness of tony
that tony is he still is still the man
and that's what i've said too i mean
back when i was calling him out trying
to fight him which the timeline didn't
work out last time he wanted to fight me
like
three weeks after the abu dhabi fight or
whatever um so
he still is the scariest one of the
scariest guys in the division justin
gates one of the scariest guys in the
division so it's it's nice to come in
and have these these crazy i mean it's
it's even just a
a uh an experience for myself
for me to grow as a human being you know
being thrown into these fires being
thrown into these these places that
these places where people watch and they
say man that's a that's a crazy
scenario let's see how he comes out and
i and so far have i lost fights
absolutely but i've grown as a human
being i'm happy with my career i'm happy
with where i'm at i'm happy with where
my life is and how it is so
but look what we're talking about
you actually made the right choice man
like we're talking about conor mcgregor
tony ferguson major pay-per-views like
clearly it's worked out man it's working
out well so i'm well you know i'm
rooting for you man i'm room for you
appreciate it you kind of touched i'm
sorry i'm starting i'm you know all
right good conversations yeah that's
what we do we'll smash this after we're
gonna crush all this food yeah but
before you go i do a segment where i
give every fight that comes on the show
some kicks from my wife at suplex in
philly
these are for you you got some fashion
on you
you know i couldn't let's go you're a
legend man these are legendary shoes
they're my favorite silhouette of all
times the jordan ones but they are
missouri tiger colors
oh yes and my boy said mr chandler
please wear these and enjoy these the
pollen jordan ones from suplex
philadelphia dude are you kidding me
lacking black and gold baby little
missouri tiger fighter
you were the man that's so sick weirdos
man i will dude so enjoy the kicks man i
can't wait for your next fight we gotta
get you on a calves fight companion
after your next fight right here
michael chandler ladies and gentlemen
super thick from my wallet to my check i
don't want it if it's skinny but i need
it if it's thick
need a thick girl
put it big boy i need everything i get
super thick boy